hier hält man arbeite habe ich die
prüfung und da haben wir uns erst einmal
die masken basteln müssen habe ich mir
mal die schutzmasken
das ist das erste mal aufsetzen wenn ihr
gästehaus und 17 schutzmasken campino
und doch ist da rüber über ein cello
wichtig ist dass der fürst und wenn
jetzt der herr der abnahme
und jetzt das die zum ziel haben wir nur
ein schutz sein zugleich bot er vom
ersten einsatztag geworden
[Musik]
und dann sagen wir zudem erschwert wurde
die prüfung stattfinden zügig hinein
gehen weil das nämlich müssen ausland
weiter ich weiß also zügig da hingehen
und wann genau den anweisungen des guten
alten folgen noch um einen raum erregung
noch haben wir über gemacht kniebeugen
liegestützen und es hat durchmarschiert
geschaut ob es dichtes und wollen spaß
hat noch immer nichts verspürt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das schöne daran ist man merkt nichts
dann ist positiv highlight war hoffen
und schutzdienst wo man die ganzen leute
griffe durchgenommen haben und als ja
ganz gut die haben wir das erste mal mit
der kamera schießen dürfen
und mrs mit dem raschen vorweg und sonst
wie hier eine opern und torlos ist nun
zum auftrieb sorgte laufzeit genau und
deshalb laden und geladen
tja und das wärmer als üben
[Musik]